good morning john i just wanted to let
you and everybody know that i'm not
making a video today
uh we said a thing a while back that
like hey
you don't have to make a video every day
you can have some days that you take off
you know like i just looked at my
calendar on
tuesday i had some time on tuesday to
make a video and i was like but i hadn't
seen your video yet you hadn't uploaded
your video during that time
and also like i had like some surprise
curveballs that came my way
family things and so i wanted to
prioritize those things
which i think everybody understands that
we do
and would do and should do and like you
don't have to tell me like
we support that of course you support
that i unders i get that which is one of
the things i love about this
i think that it is clear that we are not
focused
right now and haven't for a while on
growth like this is a thing that
everybody here is doing together
even if you just watch and never comment
and you're not
excite like maybe you're not even
excited about pizza miss
maybe you're just like coming for i
don't know i don't know whatever it is
for you you're part of it and i think
that like we need to
understand that generally about the
media that we engage with is just
by being there you are part of it i've
been thinking a lot about how we don't
know what we're signing up for when we
sign up for
the thing that we end up doing you asked
me to do this
in 2007 i said yep
what a concept and then
here we are it's 20 20
the future jet packs actually
we now we actually have the iron man
suit and the thing that this
is would be
not this it would either not exist or it
would be deeply different if it weren't
for the
people who engage with it if only just
watching not even clicking the like
button if only just by clicking on the
thing and watching the video
it would not be this thing did i have
something to do with what it is yeah you
did too
john but like but we are so
lucky that it was possible to make
something like this
and it's only possible to make something
like this because
the people who engage with it
the people who give us their attention
and we need to find things like that to
engage with and do it and let it be part
of what we are and part of how we figure
out how to imagine the world it's so
crappy right now
and i know that my brain is designed to
more heavily weight the bad stuff than
the good stuff
and so i know that when people are
trying to influence me
and the rest of the world they're going
to focus on the bad stuff
and they're going to make me think less
of everything
in order to get me to not vote or in
order to get me to
to buy a thing that's going to make me
feel better about myself for a moment
there's a thing called anchoring bias i
think about a lot where you have certain
ideas that you go
to your go-to ideas and i think it's an
impossible thing to avoid and since it's
impossible to avoid you have to pick
good anchors
and one of the things that i anchor to
is the idea of negativity bias
so i'm using my anchoring bias to anchor
to the idea that my negativity bias
exists
and that just reminds me that the world
is probably
and people are probably better than i
think
and that's at least something anyway all
that is beside the point i'm just here
to
tell you that i'm not gonna make a video
this week and i know that it's okay that
i don't make a video this week
even though i have made a video every
week on my day
for like more than 10 years and so it
feels really weird not to
okay that's all john i'll see you on
tuesday